Matthew starts off this hour in
Minnesota hey Matthew how are you good
how are you doing Dave better than I
deserve what's up I just want to say
welcome back from your vacation thank
you so my question is I am currently
working full time as well as my wife and
I'm working part-time a few days a week
delivering pizzas and I just want it to
be more weird so I signed up or I
applied for another part-time job to
bring in more income but at the same
time I am feeling like I need to do more
of a balance between family and paying
off debt and that's where I feel stuck
okay so I was worried you were like how
old are your children he is going to be
six in May okay and in what way is he
being harmed by you working why just of
me not being home a lot of lot in the
evenings and he goes to school at during
the day okay and how much debt do you
have we started at 85,000 and we are
down to almost 78 okay so you're making
a little progress okay yeah what's your
household income our household income is
around 85 to 90 what kind of debt is
this it's student loans car payment
medical debt how much is owed on your
car it is around 22,000 okay well I mean
there's two parts to this one is some
common sense that you have to be around
us or your child obviously okay the
other part of this is
and I'm from a different generation so
bear with me okay but when I was when I
first became a Christian a guy came to
our church and he said when you have
little daughters date take your
daughter's on a date dress up and take
them to McDonald's or dress them up and
take them to a fine restaurant or
whatever and I thought man that's a
great idea
date your daughters right so your key so
you get to know your kids you spend time
with your kids and and it establishes a
bond between the dad and the daughter
and I think it's a great idea still I
think you ought to do it still okay make
me curtain reason with me she thinks
it's a great idea but here's what's
weird if you interview and it's been
done by the way Rachel Cruise or Denise
Whittemore and you ask them they will
tell you dad took us on dates all the
time you know what the truth is five
times that's the truth five times I did
that and I got credit for all the time
and so the point is with little guys
that they do view the world differently
than us they're not as wrote and they
don't have as much grasp of time and so
you taking him for doughnuts
at the Krispy Kreme or the Dunkin Donuts
and spending an hour and a half with him
at 7:00 a.m. on Saturday morning is
gonna feel like you spent three days
with him you see what I'm saying
so that that's the kind of balance
against what you're saying and by the
way whether you were out of debt or
whether you're working a lot or not that
works okay my son lost a football coach
okay Denise his husband's football coach
and he's a world-class guy he's a
world-class dad in the fall he does not
see his kids she's a widow
she's a football Widow in the phone I
mean we and she signed up for that she
married a football coach so no whining
yeah and so that's what you get and she
has a six-year-old son by the way my
grandson and okay and yet I would tell
you the bill would amore as a
world-class dad he finds a moment or two
even during football season to grab
William his son and spend a little time
with him and it magnifies in the kids
head and then when they're not doing
football
he's game on with the kids okay so when
you get out of debt you'll be game on
with the kids when you're not doing debt
free so all of that to take a little bit
of the guilt-tripping you're giving
yourself off of you and saying hey
working real hard for the good of your
family for a short period of time so you
never have to work like that again is
probably worth it do balance it out do
use some wisdom but don't be guilted
guilt in yourself too heavily they'll be
okay they'll be okay when I started this
business I was working 16 hours a day I
would come in at 8:00 and I'd leave here
at 11:00 and I did that when our kids
were little and I did that for a couple
years
our kids have benefited from that I live
like no one else worked like no one else
now work like no one else it just took a
month off right so you know it's a
there's a balance through the scope of
your life there's a period of time here
that you're gonna be out of balance do
it with wisdom catch those special
moments with your son don't completely
abandon him I'm not suggesting that I
don't want him to have emotional
problems or developmental issues and I
want you to be a good thing but also
want to let you off the hook and say
you're being a much better dad than
someone who didn't even have sense
enough to ask this question right you're
okay and and right and another thing too
is uh one person told me that kids don't
remember how much kind they remember
what you did exactly that's well that's
my point about the the donut thing or
the dates right right it's like I got
credit for months and months and months
and years of dating my daughters and I
didn't do it
that's the truth I intended to do better
than I did but I pretty much like five
times each I mean it really but I but I
got it did so much emotional good that
it expanded just exactly what you just
said and so that's why I told you that
story it's not to say don't do it it's
just to say you don't have to guilt-trip
and go home we're really bad dad because
I didn't do all of check all of these
boxes perfectly the very fact that you
asked this question says you're a
world-class dad period you're a
world-class dad you're a hero hey man
thank you for calling you do good man